steven strange breaks the entire
universe in spider-man no way home isn't
this guy supposed to be a doctor we're
going mad trying to figure out what
exactly he did in this movie
the first surprise cameo fans receive in
no way home is courtesy of charlie cox's
matt murdock aka daredevil for mcu fans
who didn't tune into netflix's marvel
series before the introduction of disney
plus this may not seem like a big deal
however this opens up a world of
possibilities to seriously expand phase
4 of the mcu the cameo itself is a
somewhat frivolous one in a scene at
peter's apartment we see that
manhattan's coolest lawyer has taken on
peter as a client while he deals with
the fallout of mysterio exposing his
identity and jay jonah jameson blaming
him for mysterio's death however we
don't know much of anything about how
this team-up actually happened does
peter know matt's secret identity did
matt seek out peter or did peter
approach matt
this is over
who the hell are you my name is matthew
murdock i'm your attorney
additionally this is the first we've
heard from matt since the end of the
netflix series and we don't have a lot
to go on about what he's up to now
beyond the fact that his enhanced senses
are still going strong and he's still
lawyering up for new yorkers who need
him at this point we're not even sure if
the events of the netflix series
actually happened in this universe or if
this is just a soft reboot of the
character in phase 4 of the mcu either
way it's cool to see him but what
exactly does this mean for the mcu as a
whole before the release of no way home
kevin feige revealed to cinemablend that
if matt murdock ever made an appearance
in future mcu projects charlie cox would
be playing him now that promise has come
true but we still don't know what the
future holds with this cameo appearance
being so small it seems safe to assume
that we can expect more devilish
goodness on the way from matt murdock
and maybe some of his friends too
2002 called and they want their
spider-man back unfortunately they can't
have him he's ours now
pizza time whether it's mary jane watson
gwen stacy or michelle jones spider-man
has always been ruled by one thing love
during tobey maguire's spider-man
trilogy peter's love for mj grounds the
films no matter how many times they make
up and break up fans still root for them
to succeed the couple has a rough go of
it in the third film when peter goes a
little off the deep end but the couple
reconciles in the film's last moments
fans are left in peace with the
understanding that this couple is on the
way to being wrapped up together in a
nice tidy web but in an audacious move
no way home takes the step of casting
doubt on the status of the original
peter's relationship with mj when toby
maguire's peter gets asked if he has
someone in his life he says it's
complicated oh man peter goes on to say
they made it work whatever that means
it's unclear if he's looking back on
problems the couple worked out long ago
or if things are still tense between
them these days this version of peter
parker is a fully grown adult and fans
wouldn't be blamed for hoping that he'd
have his love life sorted out by now
mary jane and peter aren't necessarily
destined for a happy ending but
considering how much of a nostalgia fest
this movie is it would have been nice if
the movie hadn't left this version of
their relationship in such a complicated
place
we know that ned leeds is a wizard when
it comes to technology but could he have
actual magical abilities too sure you
can give anybody on the street some of
doctor strange's hardcore sorcerer gear
but that doesn't mean just anyone could
use it if magic were as universal as say
using tony stark's tech then every
avenger would cast spells and take names
no way home is jam-packed with content
so it's easy to miss that ned's affinity
for creating portals isn't just the work
of strange's sling ring we don't see
peter or mj accidentally creating
portals with strangest gear so it feels
pretty safe to say that ned has some
natural sorcerer skills for one reason
or another it's not like sorcery is easy
after all
as it stands now ned's chances of being
wong sorcerer apprentice are likely shot
given that neither of them even
remembers any of this happening however
it could still foreshadow a pretty
impressive and unexpected arc for ned in
future movies
the mcu peter's mission to cure all of
the crossover villains of their evil
tendencies and send them home as
productive law-abiding citizens is a
noble one however he doesn't put much
thought into what will happen to them
and their world after he plops them all
back in their own universes first and
foremost every villain that our trio of
peter parker's helps comes from
different points in the timeline for
toby maguire's universe we have the
green goblin who dies at the close of
the first film doc ock who perishes in
the second and sand man coming from the
third then we have andrew garfield's foe
the lizard from the first the amazing
spider-man and electro wreaking havoc in
the follow-up if peter sends each
villain back to the point they were at
before they appeared in the mcu but
they're unexpectedly good people now
then their timelines will be in shambles
creating countless variants think about
it if green goblin goes back to the
moment before his death as a regular
human cured of evil tendencies then he
probably never dies if he never dies
harry never picks up where he left off
if that doesn't happen then harry
doesn't die either at this point the
time variants authority would have a
field day with this case a lot of how
this whole multiverse thing works has
yet to be fully hashed out in the mcu
and until it's all laid out in an easy
to understand fashion we're going to be
left scratching our heads
near the end of the film dr strange
casts a spell that causes the entire
world to forget they ever knew peter
parker now when peter asks strange to
cast the spell when even more
multiversal villains are about to emerge
in his own universe it seems like it's
the same spell as the beginning making
people forget peter's identity as
spider-man instead this time strange
entirely erases peter parker from
everyone in the world's memory not even
ned and mj know who he is it's tragic
but the semantics of the spell don't
make a whole lot of sense strange's
spell work is usually not perfect but
this spell seems so contradictory that
it shouldn't really work basically how
can a spell make people forget who peter
is but remember spider-man when peter
and spider-man are the same person sure
spidey wears masks and sometimes a
billion dollar iron man nanotech suit
and some truly creepy spider legs but
he's still peter parker fans have to
seriously suspend disbelief to accept
that the whole world remembers
spider-man's existence but forgets peter
altogether if people remember spider-man
then they are remembering peter
spider-man is just peter in a funny
outfit amnesia surrounding his secret
identity is one thing because both
aspects of himself still exist people
would simply forget their connection
this is a whole new ball game and we
know so little about the components of
strange's spell that it's difficult to
parse out precisely what happens and why
this is headache inducing comic books
are hard
so scooby do this crap
now that everyone has forgotten peter's
existence he seemingly misses out on
graduation college admission and
everything else his future may have held
as it stands peter parker doesn't exist
anymore so what exactly is his five-year
plan now the movie teases us on peter's
plans in the form of a ged book it looks
like our nerdy superhero isn't ready to
give up on his mit dreams just yet but
without officially existing it's unclear
how he would even take something as
simple as a ged do records of peter
still exist somewhere and it's just the
memory of him that's erased that doesn't
seem likely because if traces of him
still existed mj and ned at the very
least would notice pictures of him
floating around and wonder who on earth
is haunting their photos as it stands it
seems like peter parker is a ghost and
ghosts don't go to college or get their
geds it's a pretty big bummer of a plot
point to close out what until now was a
pretty lighthearted trilogy
after the world's peter centric memory
wipe we watched peter swing into action
in a new shiny spandex suit that looks
like it hopped right out of an 80s
exercise video it's unclear what
happened to his original suit if
anything maybe he just has an identity
crisis to be fair he loses everyone he's
ever loved in the span of a second so we
wouldn't blame peter for going through a
good old-fashioned pre-midlife crisis
it's probably what the doctor ordered
however we have no clue whether or not
his suit even exists in this timeline
which begs a larger question do peter's
other suits and text still exist in this
timeline if his gear still does exist
what exactly was the point of stowing it
all away
sure they don't know peter but the
avengers are typically smart enough to
know when something's up on this large
of a scale don that crappy super tragic
suit head to avengers tower and ask for
help better yet why doesn't peter go to
strange if peter brings up his conundrum
to other heroes they'll probably be
stricken by how weird the gaps in their
memory are and the fact that they don't
know spidey's identity he even has the
chance to say something when he meets
happy but he stays quiet what gives
parker
let's back up to the events of
spider-man homecoming when all of this
was more simple remember vulture shady
dad to peter's fleeting love interest a
whole lot has happened since peter
bailed on his homecoming to chase down
his date's villainous father yet the
post-credits scene of that movie teased
vulture's future in the mcu a future
that so far we haven't seen one of the
most defining things about the mcu's
vulture aka adrian toombs is that by the
end of spider-man homecoming he knows
spider-man's real identity he knows
peter parker is a superhero it's kind of
a big deal if the mcu ever does bring
vulture back how are they going to pay
off vulture's knowledge if he doesn't
remember peter parker would he even
remember why he's in jail a simpler
question is how come we don't see
vulture play a part in this villain
mashup to begin with strange's spell
called fourth villains of spider-man
from alternate universes would it have
been outside the realm of possibility
for an alternate version of the vulture
or even mysterio to show up to
there are multiple realities peter this
is earth dimension 616. i'm from
earth833 you get the point it feels like
no way home is at its most confusing
when it tries to justify its own plot at
its worst it feels like the whole thing
is engineered to make some very specific
characters show up regardless of whether
or not it makes sense
our spidey senses are tingling after
that post-credit scene and no way home
many spider-man fans agree that the
introduction of venom to the third sam
raimi spidey film was the worst part of
the original trilogy but after all these
years it might be time to reacquaint
spider-man with venom and based on
eddie's appearance in the mcu's world
that might be the mash-up we see when we
glimpse peter parker again as it turns
out eddie leaves a little symbiote gift
in peter's universe before he's sucked
back into his own that is after learning
everything there is to know about the
avengers the blip and the past decade of
superhero shenanigans so how exactly
will venom fit into this world who will
host the dastardly beast it could be
that the series introduces an mcu
version of eddie brock or maybe the
symbiote will end up with another
villain for a little while either way
there's a lot of trouble brewing in the
future for this new bold marvel
cinematic multiverse
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spiderman no way homer coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]